Farms around the world are struggling to protect their crops.
The price of synthetic fertilizers is soaring due to the war in Ukraine...
...and supply chain disruptions.
But farmers in Vermont are finding relief from an unexpected source:...
...human pee.
Dean Hamilton is one of a handful of farmers in the area...
...participating in an experimental program...
...trading chemical fertilizers for human urine.
The liquid is rich in phosphorus, nitrogen, and potassium,...
...important nutrients that the plants need to thrive.
About 80% of the nitrogen...
...and 2/3 of the phosphorus in our bodily waste are in the urine,...
...which surprises people.
The Rich Earth Institute started the urine nutrient reclamation program in 2012.
The urine has nutrients in it.
If you put those nutrients on the grass, they grow.
There's more grass.
More grass means more cows.
The beef is cheaper.
The whole system is more tied together, more cyclical.
Everybody wins.